hey guys Henri Goulding from last
Christmas I am going to be playing with
BuzzFeed slay on a right first up
Christmas music before December
definitely a sleigh November comes
around you have literal license to play
any musical sort of Christmasy song you
wish and I expect last Christmas to be
blaring in every shop that I walk into
because that's usually when you know
that it's time to start buying presents
I've heard it my entire life so to be
doing a film which is essentially
created around the lyrics of last
Christmas it has given me a renewed
sense of love for George Michael and and
his music in general car costumes we do
like a little bit of car costumes I
think I don't know how safe they are and
but you know there's like antlers I
would say slay because why not it's
Christmas you can literally get away
with the ugliest sweaters on earth why
not dress your car or stupid life next
question ugly sweaters ugly Christmas
sweaters definitely a slain I think the
uglier the better the more ironic the
more fantastic
you are amiss if you don't have anything
stupendously disgusting on whilst
opening your presents I've been in Asia
for the past 10 years and it's very hot
on Christmas Day if no spin around so
this year hopefully I'll get an ugly
Christmas sweater Black Friday shopping
massive nay consumerism at its worst
they just drive you to spend money that
you don't need to spend on a day which
you should be relaxing and enjoying your
time with your family and friends go
into the cinema watching I think this
year is like new Star Wars is out
and all sorts don't do Black Friday
shopping guys caroling slay I mean who
doesn't love Christmas Carol is I don't
think I've ever been a part I think as a
kid I tried to just get some extra money
with a friend and sing terrible sort of
Christmas carols a youngster trying to
get some extra pocket money but they do
the job and they're there to bring the
festive spirit ashley secrets answer /
white elephants I actually do Secret
Santa gifts when I'm with my friends so
I would say sleigh it's the best way not
to have to buy 15 presents and you can
just focus on one good present to give
somebody and see their reaction when you
bring out something absolutely
ridiculous so Ashley
colleague Christmas trees May Christmas
tree has to be green it has to be real
it cannot be bright pink or blue or
whatever with flashy sort of lights
embedded no it has to be a nice
beautifully smelling pine that kind of
sheds in your house and you religiously
have to vacuum up after it ecologically
speaking we should be going for reusable
Christmas trees but decorated bids come
across decorated bids before for
Christmas for that matter I remember
when there was like oh there's like
Merman beards where they put like tinsel
and and glitter those were ridiculously
awesome so I would say a couple of bits
of tinsel in there I wouldn't call this
a beard i have never grown a beard
because i have patches and it's very
difficult and rather depressing that
they don't connect from my hair to the
rest of my face so i've never seen this
in my life upside down christmas tree is
this a thing
why for Australians internet we do know
you're like that crazy stepchild that we
love to hate so please give up on the
upside down courage features named
Fisher SantaCon they're having so much
fun how could I say nay to that slay
Christmas weddings nay what a way to
distract people from a wonderful holiday
than to force them to come to your
wedding
Christmas weddings no this is like the
rest of the year to do something special
and Christmas isn't one of those days
matching pajamas yay for sure a hundred
percent ice skating a massive sleigh we
have a lot of ice skating in the movie a
very special moment happens on the
ice-skating rink so I would definitely
say it gets you in the mood and
especially here in New York you have the
Rockefeller Center where that iconic
skating rink is and I've been there with
a big Christmas tree in the Statue and
all the hordes and hordes of tourists to
brave the tourists I say sleep kissing
under the mistletoe it's like for sure
sometimes it's the only kiss that people
get the whole unit extracting Christmas
decorations yes as long as it's not your
house you know I mean like as soon as
Christmas comes and goes you have to
unravel and you have to put back all of
those lights and it's a thing and the
tangles and the mess adds your bearing
towards me
not too many travelers bit extravagant
Christmas decorations gingerbread houses
nay a bland eggnog sleigh lovebird
eggnog especially strong eggnog that
gets you sleepy after a big Christmas
meal and you just want to wrap up in a
cozy blanket and sit by fire and tell
stories and play ball games which is
what we do every Christmas then we have
a guys sleigh or neigh with BuzzFeed
with me Henry Goulding don't forget last
Christmas is out in cinemas November
go bring your family your mom your dad
stir for Kreiger for a locker for a hug
it is quite literally the perfect
Christmas movie by
[Music]